were you born in hawaii i wasn't born in
hawaii i was born here in san francisco
but i did a lot of my growing up there
so yes it was it was amazing i don't
know i don't think no tell me
[Laughter]
what's more you say for years i've
always said when we were there you gave
me a big speech like this is my land
[Laughter]
[Music]
now all of a sudden saying friend that
was saying friend that i transferred but
we were there
[Laughter]
this is a cliff where i was born
hawaii was beautiful
beautiful uh you know mountainside and
lushness and and uh we shot in this
beautiful place called kuala ranch where
uh jurassic park the original jurassic
park was shot and the ones uh after that
as well and it was just amazing but you
didn't like it he hated it no no this is
the problem i didn't i didn't like it at
all i mean outside of the the spiritual
grounds that you took me to and i swore
you even sung a song you were like
i have to share that with you
we'll talk about it later
like you were like come on
beautiful blake sexiest man in the world
all those things and yes she is the
sexiest man yeah
yeah he's doing well there that's a good
shot right there look at you look
no but to cheer us up when you started
kind of being interested in girls you
weren't as that cool or smooth with it
no no no not at all i don't believe it
no no i really i went through puberty at
like 27.
this was a freak thing yeah it was not
good yeah
who's the girl who was the girl in
school the first the first girl
the first well i was obsessed with this
this girl uh uh fiona gorczynski who uh
uh is she yeah
she's she said and she used to actually
she used to take the bus the the
opposite way of my actual home and i
would get on the bus just to sit next to
her wow for 45 minutes the wrong way oh
there's something wonderful about there
was something wonderful
i love it when you're young it's so cute
when you're older it's just stalking
you're like on some kind of watch list
yeah but but i remember when i was i
couldn't have been more than i don't
know 11 years old and i and i i was just
about to get off the bus because enough
is enough i'm about to enter like
seattle or something so
i'm starting to get off the bus and i
decided to like kind of hit her with
like this cool look or something like
this like one of these like real sort of
don johnson miami
[Laughter]
and i sort of delay a little too long
and the bus doors close on my backpack
with my backpack and the bus just starts
to leave
[Laughter]
the bus driver finally stops opens the
door let's releases my you know idiot
bag backpack and i i could never look at
her again
yeah that was terrible yeah she's
looking at you now
can you imagine she's like he's the guy
with that backpack
he's the idiot with the ren and stimpy
backpack
but i have to say what's extraordinary
is you and chris pine dressed in 90 days
fashion still manage to look very good
thank you so much um yeah i know it can
be tricky if you go too much with the
with the 80s fashion it can look campy
very easily
but it was very important for us to make
uh diana look timeless and elegant
and i think that chris completely
totally pulled off the the fanny pack
look
i mean yeah i mean a lot of people
wouldn't look good in that but that's
fine i don't know he's the only one
i want to explain why we don't call him
fanny pack graeme no i don't
rock your character's name is a dr
smolder bravestone yes and uh so all the
characters have strengths
so one of your strengths is the
smoldering an actual smolder yes it just
takes over uh and i have no control over
it and did you know you could smolder
like did you kind of think yeah when you
do when you read it you've got to go oh
yeah i'll do my smolder
you know
i'd take you exactly no it didn't come
yet oh okay okay
that literally is where it came from
that what you're seeing and this is why
he looked at me because it's so
frustrating just go ahead tell tell the
story about your stupid smell
it's one of those things that you know
as we're developing the script and think
well what could be a fun thing what if a
fun thing one of the fun things was he
he has this ability to smolder and it
just takes over him he has no control of
it uh and uh and it's just one of those
things graham that
god delivered i signed for it and then
i just do it and everyone everyone likes
it and everyone loves it except one
individual
everyone i'm gonna tell you what it is
okay now we we are we are very close we
were very close as friends and you know
in this position he's a producer on the
film so sometimes i just bit my tongue
so this idea came up from a producer
like mentality oh you know what would be
great for this character
if he's smoldered not like what
you know if he did a thing and i was
like what that got to do with that being
like in the game
it's a thing and he's like and then he's
brought him back he was like my mom used
to do it to me when i was
and that's why we listened to him
because he brought it back
everything got tied back to hawaii
that's how he did it graham
can we see us smolder can we see oh i'd
be happy to great sit back for a
[Applause]
second here
can we have a little music maybe
something that's a little ominous okay
here we go wow yes okay okay here we go
you can do it to me
yes
you're ready here we go
[Music]
hmm
beautiful very good
thank you
thank
[Applause]
now we're having
that's why you are who you are
ryan the thing about you growing up i
love the the you told stories about
growing up because your dad it was like
he was training you for paparazzi he was
very snap happy yeah he was i was
actually the saddest moment in our
childhood and these are uptown problems
was when they switched from film to
digital because to my father that was
just like every day was the lottery i
mean it was amazing because you could
just take pictures and pictures and
pictures thousands of them it could be
like thousands of pictures of just a
meatloaf that's blurry and what he would
do is at the end of the night he would
email everyone in the family all the all
the photographs as well yeah but the the
thing is this is back when like the
internet was made of a fax machine of
wood like it was just
uploaded like that
and then you would download all of these
things and like you like it was so much
material to download you'd feel like the
lights dim in your home
this must be costing a fortune and i got
i used to say to him i was like dad can
you stop you don't need to piss on every
phone like we don't need to see the
blurry photo of the ceiling you took
when you like just edit yourself never
did so after a while and i i i mean i
deeply regret this now as an adult male
i have deep regrets of what i did but i
would take the camera sometimes in the
middle of dinner and i'd just go in the
bathroom and i just i did just grab a
quick shot of my penis
and then he'd email it to everybody nana
and kathy uncle tim
uh uh
gramps got a few of those
they think it was his though um no i
well that was his concern which is what
actually in a weird way made the whole
thing work for me so after that he
became a strict editor so you'd get just
two lovely family photos at the end of
an evening not 60 000 shots of a of a
you know mashed potato
this is what i was just thinking as i
was listening to that story which by the
way i didn't hear a word of okay just
now because like did you did you grow up
with a kid like in elementary school or
whatever and you were always kind of
amazed by the kid it was like the kid
over there doing the jokes and the
talking and all that kind of and then
the rest of the class kind of was in awe
every time that i'm with him it's like
somebody spiked my water with lsd
and i'm just sitting there
in awe this is lovely no but it's not
it's not
meant to be a compliment i'm sorry i'm
not supposed to have lsd no yeah this is
no i'm literally i found myself halfway
through the story going like this
you just you're high on ryan that's
right i heard something about mashed
potatoes of facts with wood and your dad
yeah
that's actually the name of my memoir
way to blow it thank you spoiler alert
that music you walked onto did you hear
it i did yes that's that's your music it
is the iconic rock music yes so did that
bring back happy memories of bad
memories oh happy memories oh good yes
no i mean i was able to do a lot of cool
things you know snoop was there on a
couple occasions yeah he was able to
witness it there was a lot of ass
kicking going on back then
but we got this is the classic i think
this is a classic rock pose with the
eyebrow the that signature eyebrow look
at that yes
and this is your kind of this is the
kind of the pre-match is this the
pre-match that yeah that's like the it's
the pre-match it's the preamble it's a
talking trash that is a i had a catch
phrase that that that went with is that
the it doesn't matter that's it doesn't
matter how did it doesn't matter because
it doesn't sound like a catch phrase how
did it work as a catchphrase
well uh
whoever i was in the ring with and snoop
has been there on many occasions right
so whoever i was in the ring with so for
example if it were you and i would be
like um graham what do you think you're
gonna do tonight when we get in the ring
well i think it doesn't matter
so
that's how it kind
that's how of kind of works and then the
it's the shouting and the body but then
if you smell if you smell what the rock
is cooking how did that work then in in
a sentence oh well that that works in a
sentence a statement a question it works
anywhere right when you wake up right
before you go to bed it's just you could
just say it if you smell what the rock
is quick yeah but you got to say it
probably with a little bit like you know
you shout that one as well
mmm it's hard i generally have a
microphone when i'm doing it well hello
go for it
i don't know they don't want to hear me
though i think they do
okay
okay all right here we go so it's it all
starts with the base okay okay you got
to open your legs a little bit okay okay
you got to kind of do one of these yeah
lean forward a little bit yeah okay come
back
and then right here is where you gotta
do a little tongue thing okay this is
what it gets interesting if you smell it
then at the end you gotta now you gotta
do that
what the rock and then there's a little
pause there's like a big pregnant pause
so you have to do it right right so the
audience kind of leans in a little bit
is cooking and then that
[Applause]
oh i have been waiting years to come to
the grand orange show to do that so
they've waited all their lives
dear diary finally
[Applause]
[Music]
you